all right we start tonight with a Fox
News Alert the president Donald Trump
who announced he is running for
re-election last night he will join us
in just a few minutes an exclusive
one-on-one interview you don't want to
miss it and unlike the media mob well
let him talk and we're not playing
gotcha
last night the president officially
kicked off his reelection bid a massive
rally 20,000 seat arena in Orlando
packed to the brim more than 150,000
people by the way wanted to be there and
many more stood in an overflow area
outside with some literally waiting in
line over 40 plus hours just to get in
well I guess the greatest show on earth
considering there's no guitar there's no
Billy Joel Elton John Jimi Hendrix and I
don't think the president sings well but
the president and thousands upon
thousands of pumped up supporters now I
would say it's fair to compare his
crowds to any of his radical-socialist
the 24 Democrats that want to go up
against him in the next presidential
election like for example sleepy creepy
crazy Uncle Joe has he ever filled an
arena one time Obama did I don't think
Joe has only 600 people came to his
first campaign rally Elizabeth Warren to
her credit she did slightly better she
had a whopping 3,500 supporters that
showed up in her home state of
Massachusetts meanwhile the one-time
rising star of the Democratic Party
robert francis bado bozo O'Rourke he
amassed a thousand people roughly 120 at
the size of the president's rally look
at your screen now the enthusiasm gap is
massive but not everyone sees the
handwriting on the wall so-called
journalists so call pundits the ones
that have been lying to you for two-plus
years and that it pushed conspiracy
theories and hoaxes and never thought
Donald Trump would win well they use
last night's rally to trash the
president and his supporters and by the
way as we start the show tonight I also
start with a thank you because by we had
well over 5 million people just tuned in
to this one hour never mind you know
Tucker's hour never mind
the other cable channels
nevermind the other media outlets very
impressive showing by the president last
night we're not the media mob we are
more than yes smelly people that like
Walmart that cling to our guns God
Bibles and religion we're not
irredeemable deplorable z' although some
people think so and it appears the mob
has learned absolutely positively
nothing from 2016 let's take a look it
turned into a lock her up chant tonight
sure and that's a reflection of Donald
Trump's followers just as we hold the
president accountable we should hold his
followers who make those chants
accountable as well it was a very dark
speech though it was almost like the
live-action version of American carnage
his inauguration address it didn't feel
like a celebration of America being
great again it is grievance Palooza this
is everyone everyone there is there's
not this affirmative feeling about great
the greatness of our country or some
vision for the future there were a lot
of people there classic Florida there's
a little bit of a Turing of cueing on
there were people wearing their formal
flip-flops and their and their two cargo
pants no disrespect to the king of rock
and roll oh but this is Elvis in 77 just
kind of lumbering across the stage
sweating I have a message for the
conspiracy theorist on fake news NBC
yeah the conspiracy network the
Americans have showed up last night in
flip flops and cargo shorts well they
will be the people to choose the next
president they're the ones that were
right in 2016 and all of you were wrong
I suggest you go back and watch yourself
on election day and I know the exit
polls showed that Donald Trump didn't
win and you all started out your
coverage giddy and happy and uplifted
and you thought you had it in a bag and
then all of a sudden well late North
Carolina came around and Wisconsin came
around and Michigan came around and
Pennsylvania came around and Ohio came
around and yeah Florida came around and
what happened it didn't work out the way
you wanted and you could see the
depression set in an immediate mob an
amazing night The Forgotten men and
women in this country the ones that
suffered the most under Biden Obama
the people that make this country great
every day they didn't buy into your lies
a conspiracy theories and your hoax the
last two years and as the president's
been setting records as it relates to
the economy and jobs and everything else
well they have turned off the nitric
victory not nightly vitriol and fake
news CNN and MSNBC they've had enough of
all of your disgusting Hitler
comparisons to Jeff Zucker you run fake
news CNN your ratings are in the tank I
know Jimmy Acosta's begging to be on my
show his book was 550 on Amazon today
you can barely break a million at any
hour during the day we had over five
million last night nobody's watching you
let your quote journalist Don Lemon say
this on your network last night you
should be ashamed of yourself take a
look
think about the despicable people we've
had in history okay now I'm gonna use an
extreme example think about Hitler think
about any of those people if you could
look back on in history would you say
well I'm so glad that that person was
allowed a platform so that they could
spread their hate and propaganda in lies
it would you say it probably wasn't the
right thing to do to spread that because
you knew in the moment that that was a
bad person and they were doing bad
things not only were they hurting people
they were killing people and so I just
think that but I think that the example
matters and that's a very extreme
example what really happened was this
when the president's six plus minutes
into a speech last night so that all
those fake news people in the back and
then the crowd started chanting again
not chanting screaming well telling the
truth about fake news CNN that CNN sucks
CNN couldn't take the criticism and they
turned it off Don Lemon and Jeff Zucker
you need to pick up a history book every
now and then from prison reform to tax
cuts to promises made and kept
constitutional justices to the right to
try to ending burdensome regulation to
energy independence to killing that
stupid Iranian
deal - yeah recognizing Israel and
Jerusalem as the capital in Golan as
Israel's territory President Trump is
committed to preserving the freedom of
all Americans and in case you haven't
noticed because every second every
minute every hour of every day you're
focused on hating the president which is
true maybe you would have noticed that
well Obama Biden had 13 million more
Americans on food stamps after eight
years eight million more in poverty the
worst recovery since the 40 is the
lowest labor participation rate since
the 70s Lois home ownership rate in 51
years oh they took on more debt than all
43 presidents before them combined and
never hit 3% GDP and they're in there
eight years now we have record low
unemployment for African Americans for
Asian Americans Hispanic Americans women
in the workplace and youth unemployment
is literally at a 50-year low that means
kids stay out of trouble they get summer
jobs like me when I was a kid I was
rather incorrigible peace prosperity are
on the rise we're now energy independent
for the first time in 75 years the
president's approval rating by the way I
don't think he rates like most
politicians I don't think you can poll
Donald Trump honestly that's my opinion
but anyway that's not all for the first
time in many decades if you would stop
with your rage your psychosis and your
obsession and hating the president well
the Trump administration is taking major
steps to hold our massive government
bureaucracy accountable but as president
Trump is Attorney General Bill Barr the
story that you missed the biggest abuse
of power in American history corruption
on a level that is so bad that if we
don't stop it we'll lose this great
democratic republic that so many fought
bled and died for
but the corrupt 1% of a two-tier justice
system in this country they're finally
getting the attention they deserve
unfortunately you were all wrong this
program got it right and thankfully we
had an ensemble team John Solomon Gregg
Jarrett tom Fitton Sarah Anne Carter I
can't mention Jeanine Pirro
Giada Jenna but Victoria ton Singh I
can't mention everybody committed to
peeling every layer
the deep state onion and that tonight
the hills John Solomon is back with
another bombshell report now for months
we have highlighted Christopher Steele's
dirty dossier bought and paid for
Russian lies by Hillary Clinton
according to Solomon it was not the only
fraudulent document used against a trump
campaign associate in 2017 the FBI
pushed something called the black cash
ledger to obtain multiple warrants in
this case on Paul Manafort
the only problem by the way I think they
won't pull man afford to die in jail
first isolation now they want to put him
at Rikers then they want to give him a
state charges and charge them all over
again which I believe is double jeopardy
and I've always known that Muller and
his merrie team of wise men who the pit
bull and Jeanne ray Clinton's former
attorney was just bad people but the
black cash ledger which these other news
networks would never tell you about was
full of a lot of crap Solomon writes
quote the feds were warned repeatedly
the document couldn't be trusted and
likely was a fake Ukraine's top
prosecutor said the document was nothing
was not authenticated should not be used
in any way to bring accusations against
anybody Wow do you hear appeal in your
ear the ledgers key assertion manna fort
received cash payments by all accounts
are totally false